(gentle music)
- Welcome everyone.
So today, as you, like,
you already have noticed,
we are in a bit unusual location.
We were invited by Inverto,
a consulting company
that is part of Boston Consulting Group
to their Cologne office.
Yesterday evening, we arrived
from Munich here in Cologne.
We have now a full day ahead of us
meeting consultants of Inverto.
They're going to talk
to us about procurement
and supply chain consulting
as these are the two topics
that Inverto part of BCG is focusing on.
So, stick it here with me.
We are now going to have
a typical coffee break
in the morning as well, of course,
so let's get into it, hi.
- [Daniella] Hi, Heinrich, I'm Daniella.
- I'm Heinrich, Daniella, it's a pleasure.
- Hi, I'm Laura, nice to meet you.
- Hi, Laura, great for
having me, thank you.
So we got ourself the typical coffee,
so welcome to another coffee break,
you're on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, and on
my channel I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
So if you're a first time
watch off the channel,
on Firm Learning, we try to
talk about consulting topics,
career topics, especially
focused on people
in the first years of their career.
So if this is something
that interests you,
feel free to subscribe.
Today, we're going to talk
specifically about consulting.
Consulting at Inverto about procurement
and supply chain consulting.
Before we do that, let's start
with a little introductory
round so that we know
to whom we are talking here.
Can you just tell us a little bit
about your role at Inverto.
- Yes, sure, so I'm Laura,
I'm a project manager here at Inverto,
and I'm focusing on the
area of procurement,
retail and consumer goods.
And as project manager, you're responsible
for leading operatively,
the project teams,
and also exchange with
the client in regards
to the strategic path of the project.
- Good.
- I'm Daniella, I'm also a
project leader at Inverto
at the Vienna office and I'm
focusing on the industries,
healthcare, retail, and customers.
- So let's start with your background.
What did you do before
working in consulting?
- Actually, I have a PhD in astrophysics.
- Okay, that's microbe,
I'd say, understood?
So what about you, what
is your background?
What did you do before consulting?
- Yeah, so I always worked
in the retail business
and in the consumer goods business
in various firms in Germany
and also in other countries.
And I have a fashion and
consumer goods background
in that sense.
- So, what is your most
memorable moment at Inverto?
- So I think actually
at the annual conference
where we were just in France
and that was a great experience
to meet everyone in person
after this long COVID time
and see how big, tall,
or small everyone was.
- So not sure if this
question really applies
in the current situation,
but can you tell us
about your most exotic project locations?
- Of course, so, as you said, right now,
we are a lot in home office,
but usually Inverto has
projects all over the world.
And actually what is really nice right now
is that I can be on five
continents in one call.
So I really enjoyed that,
but of course I'm also looking forward
to then be onsite at the client.
(lively music)
- So I can say this for myself
that before joining consulting,
I probably did not even know
what a buying organization
at a client would do.
And for sure, also not
what procurement consulting
would be all about.
So this is exactly what we're
now going to talk about.
Thankfully, Daniella prepared
a couple of flip charts
for that and will enlighten us.
So I'd say let's get
over to the meeting room
to dig into it.
- Sure.
- So let's start with the basics.
What is procurement and supply
chain management consulting
all about?
- Usually we divide it into
direct and indirect articles.
So direct articles is
everything that flows
into the production of the article itself
that the client producers.
So for example, if you have a clothing,
so it would be everything
that is used to produce
this clothing, like the buttons,
like the fabric and so on.
Indirect on the other hand is everything
that is indirectly used
to produce this article,
which can be energy or all the utilities,
or it can also be logistics
or something like that.
- So let's look at the
different types of projects
that you would do as a
procurement consultant.
So what are the different variations
that you actually do in your job?
- Sure, I prepared here
as small flip chart.
So let me start with
the most common project,
which is reducing costs.
So clients often come to
us and they want to reduce
their costs to have a higher margin
or simply to be more
competitive at the market.
So this is for sure, one of
our most common projects.
Then we also have clients that come to us
because they want to change something
in their procurement organization.
This often happens after
a merger and acquisitions
or also for clients that want
to do an IPO, for example.
We have clients that not
only want to change something
in their procurement,
but they want to change the
whole end-to-end structure.
So they want to have a closer
look at their supply chain
to improve their efficiency and maybe also
to improve their lead times.
Then in previous years, digital became
more and more important
also for our clients
also in procurement.
This is why Inverto founded
our own digital data science department,
where they come in into our
projects if they are needed.
For a lot of our clients, design
to value is also important.
So changing the product
to maximize their impact
on the customer.
So really customer-focused product design.
And last but not least,
we have the new clients.
For example, sustainability
became very important
in the past few years
for all of our clients.
So this is also topics
that we are focusing on.
- So now that we learned
what procurement consulting
is all about, I'm glad to
have Laura here with me.
We will now talk about
what it's actually like
to be a consultant on a team,
how a typical team is set up
on such a consulting projects.
- Okay, so what we can see here
is a typical project structure
in regards to the staffing
and the people we're
having on our projects.
So at the first level we
have the managing director
or the so-called senior partner,
which is there to hold
basically the relationship
to the client and is responsible
for the whole project.
- Yeah, and here, by the way,
for those of you who have not seen it yet,
earlier this year, we did a video
with managing director, Lars,
he's an MD in the Inverto Munich office,
and he was inviting us to
join him for a full day
in BCG Inverto, Munich.
So if you're interested,
what a day in the life
of a consulting partner looks like,
I will link the video somewhere
above here, check it out.
I think it was a highly insightful video,
but sorry, let's continue.
- Thank you, so what we can
see on the next level here
is basically that we have
an associate director
or a principal, most of the times,
who's also responsible for
the upward communication
to the managing director or the partner,
and also to guide and steer the client
in highly strategic topics.
On the next level, we're
having the project lead level,
which is basically staffed
with a project manager
or a senior project manager
or various project managers,
depending on the work
streams we're working on.
- So now that I know that
most of you are likely
in the first years of your career,
or maybe a graduate thinking
about joining consulting,
likely you wouldn't start
here on the consultant
or senior consultant level.
Can you maybe share a bit more details
what really the day-to-day
activities of these people
on the project would be.
- Sure, so what we
usually do on our projects
is that we have certain work streams
the teams are working on.
And the senior consultants
are already in the lead
for those work streams
reporting to the project leads
and are also guiding and steering
our more junior colleagues,
the consultants.
So when we look at a daily
routine, a senior consultant
or also consultants having is basically
that they look at the work packages,
exchange with the client
teams on details of the spend
and details of the demands
and cost structures.
And then therefore, or
from that spend analysis
deriving the saving potential.
- I hope you found this
introduction to procurement
and supply chain consulting insightful.
And if this sparked your interest,
Inverto is sponsoring this video.
So thanks first to Inverto,
but what this means
is that Inverto is hiring
across all the European offices.
So if you are interested in a career
in procurement consulting as well,
you can check out the link
in the video description.
(upbeat music)
Now we talked a lot about
procurement consulting,
supply chain consulting,
now I'd love to also make
use of the opportunity
of having you two here as
project leads at BCG, Inverto,
just to learn a bit from you,
also potentially for all the people
in the front loading audience.
And maybe let's start indeed
with a project lead role,
because I know from my
experience in consulting,
that that was a very big step
up from being a consulting
to then suddenly being project lead.
How was this experience for you?
And can you maybe share a couple of tips
for the people also in the audience,
maybe are thinking about
becoming a project lead soon,
what did you do to become successful?
- So I think at first,
so, when I had my first project,
the first thing I noticed
that all the responsibility
suddenly is on you.
So the consultants come to you,
senior consultants, they want
to know what they should do,
but also all the others come to you.
So MDs, partners, principals,
because they want of course
to get all the knowledge
they need for the client.
So suddenly all the attention is on you
and all the other responsibility.
And that's something
you need to get used to,
but at some point you really like it.
So at least it was for me.
- Yeah, I think it's super important
to have a good structure in
regards to how you take notes,
how you organize yourself in
regards to emails and calls
and how you also structure the team
in regards to communication with you.
So, as Daniella said, you have
to answer all the questions
from client side, from team side,
from managing level in your firm.
And that's where you need
a really good structure
to have all the knowledge
condensed and ready on the spot
when you need it.
- It makes a lot of sense,
I mean, on top of that,
you said it, it's not
only your consultants,
it's on all your deed,
but the clients now are
coming to you as a man
and looking at you as
project lead and indeed,
so this always fits like the position
where just like from all directions
you're being put under pressure.
Now back at all the people in
the Firm Learning community,
I know several of you
are also still graduates
or maybe in the first years
thinking about potentially
joining consulting.
And I trust you would
all be very interested
to get your insights into
the interview process,
your silver bullet of how to be successful
in consulting interviews.
So, what tips do you have to share here?
- So I think in the moment
where you conduct the interview
with the team, I think you
have to be very structured
in regards to how you give your answers
that everyone can really
relate to what you're saying.
And you should have
prepared good questions,
which are really meaningful questions.
And that sends what you wanna know
as a potential future consultant,
but also what could be interesting
in regards to the whole conversation.
And then it's also super
important that you stay authentic
in the way you are.
So if you're not a very
strong communicator,
just don't try to overdo it or anything,
just to stay true to
yourself and just be natural
in the way that you talk, communicate
and act in the interview, I think
that's very important.
- Makes sense, yeah.
- In terms of preparation,
maybe I give you an overview
of how our interviews are structured.
So they usually take
either a whole a morning
or a whole afternoon.
It starts with an analytical test
that takes approximately an hour.
And then you will have
three interviews in a row.
You will have an interview
with a project manager
or a senior project manager,
then one with the principal
and one with an MD.
And you will do one is HR interview
where you are asked questions.
One is a case interview.
And the last one with the MD is the one
where you usually also
present part of your work.
So you have time to prepare a presentation
already beforehand, and you
present this presentation
then to the MD.
In terms of preparation,
my suggestion would be
for the analytical tests
to practice your calculation skills.
So this is something I had
to experience myself too.
So you think, yeah,
multiplying, dividing, easy,
I can do it.
It's better to practice it beforehand
because it's not so
easy to remember things
you learned 20 years ago.
So that would be one
suggestion from my side.
In terms of the case, so we
are procurement consulting.
So I would suggest have a
look at procurement levers.
So what are typically
levers that we apply,
because it's very likely
that you will get a procurement case.
(upbeat music)
- So this is now the end of
our day here today at Inverto.
First of all, thanks
again for inviting me.
Certainly I learned a lot.
I hope that it was
insightful for you as well.
So as always, if you have any questions
also to the Inverto team, feel
free to leave a comment below
in the comment section, then
we can have a look at it
and potentially also come back to you.
As always, if you took any
value at all out of this video,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the
channel to stay up to date
on all the content.
Again, if you're interested
in procurement consulting,
we'd like to check out the
career opportunities at Inverto
link to their career page
in the video description.
Big thanks also for the
members of the channel.
Thank you so much for your contribution.
My name is Heinrich, I do these
videos every single Saturday
on this channel.
So see you again next week.
This is Heinrich, bye-bye.